a lot of people are very familiar with
the technique of slow breathing or deep
breathing to try to relax but it turns
out there's a breathing technique that
it's more effective than that I call it
the power breath and the way you do it
is that you exhale for twice as long as
you inhale so you might inhale for a
count of four and exhale for a count of
eight if you really kind of worked out
maybe you can only inhale for two and
out for four when you get started and
then you kind of slow it down more as
you go
maybe inhale for eight and exhale for 16
once you get really good at it it turns
out that the reason why this works so
effectively to calm yourself down is
that it triggers a switch in your body's
nervous system from a sympathetic
nervous system state to parasympathetic
and parasympathetic is the nervous
system state that's associated with what
they call rest and digest sympathetic is
for more like fight or flight so if
you're in a kind of fight-or-flight
state and you don't want to be feeling
that way you can do this power breath
inhale for four exhale for eight and
switch just you get to decide whether
you're in fight-or-flight or rest and
digest or another one is connect they
call them calm and connect state and
this has been used effectively by people
for all sorts of things for stopping a
panic attack
for reducing the symptoms of a migraine
for dealing with muscle spasms or muscle
cramps anything you can do to get your
body to switch into that calm and
connect rest and digest state it can
help with that there's a simple reason
why this form of breathing helps switch
your body into that calm and connect
rest and digest state which is that when
you are naturally calm when you are
naturally resting and not thinking about
your breathing that is the breathing
pattern that your body adopts so you're
basically fooling your brain and body
into thinking that you're already calm
and connected that you're already at
rest by three
the way you would be breathing if you
were naturally in a state of calm a
connection